so as we get into this video about the
origins of darkside what we're going to
be doing here is we're going to be
focusing on both origins we're going to
be focusing on the original origin that
was given to us as part of Jack Kirby's
fourth world but we're also going to be
looking at the new 52 origin that was
given to us by Greg Pak and Justice
League
issue number 23 point 1 now when Jack
Kirby left Marvel to pursue a writing
career in DC almost immediately after he
arrived he basically started on the idea
of creating a series of comics telling a
self-contained story that moved away
from stories more traditionally seen in
DC Comics rather than focusing on
Superman and Batman and so on Jack Kirby
wanted to establish a mythology that was
all his own that focus on characters
with extraordinary power but that still
also maintained this representation of
the battle between good and evil and so
this idea would ultimately come to
fruition with the fourth world event or
the fourth worlds story and dark side
which would allow Jack Kirby to use
Darkseid as kind of representation the
sort of amalgamation of ultimate evil in
the new god mythology now the origin
story of Darkseid itself is actually
given to us in Jack Kirby's fourth world
issues number two through five is backup
features and what this means is that
they basically appear at the back of
each of these issues that kind of tell
us this ongoing story of how it was that
New Genesis and apocalypse came into
existence as well as a story of how it
was the dark side came to be what we
learn here is that when the world of the
old gods as to say the gods of classic
literature had come to an end that new
Genesis and apocalypse came into
existence in their place
now what Jack Kirby does here is he just
kind of throws that to us he simply just
says the old gods were there when they
supposedly died off and the new gods
came into their place and that's it
that's really just kind of the way he
throws things out there but the fact
remains here that while new Genesis is
this very lush and tranquil world which
again was designed by Jack Kirby to look
almost identical to heaven the world of
Apocalypse is a very dark and fiery
world which again is designed by Jack
Kirby to look like hell now edition
initially Darkseid was a bee named UQ's
su XA s and what we find is that he was
actually the second in line as heir to
the throne of the
world of apocalypse behind his brother
Drax now from their immediate
introduction Jack Kirby basically
establishes to us that the relationship
between Drax and USS is not a friendly
one that rather than the two of them
sharing in victories and so on and I
guess operating more on the order of
very close brothers or very close
friends instead there was a bitterness
between Drax and USS in addition to this
were Drax aspired to end the belief that
apocalypse was the home of all evil and
to basically bring a peaceful age to the
planet almost identical so the world of
New Genesis you SAS believe that fear
should be the motivating force behind
all life now eventually the time came
when Drax aspired to gain the Omega
Force which was basically this central
power force this and extremely powerful
I guess the source of energy that would
allow him to take on god-like powers and
to do so basically what he did is he had
a suit commissioned that would allow him
to channel the Omega energy into a force
that he could control but almost
immediately after Drax and put this suit
on and actually engaged in the Omega
energies themselves we find that Drax is
actually killed off and the reason why
is because you cos had been plotting for
quite some time to kill Drax and then
usurp his position as the ruler of
apocalypse once the once their mother
had died and so the result here is that
you sass actually had the protective
suit and so he simply bathed himself in
the energies of the Omega force and once
everything seems to calm down once
everything seems to come to an end he
basically emerges as the villain named
Darkseid now what we're also told here
is that he'd basically been groomed this
way that the mother of uke's ass was
extremely harsh towards him she had
mistreated him constantly then the
reason why was because if he was going
to step into the role and be the leader
of apocalypse he had to be able to lead
apocalypse properly that is to say he
had to uphold the traditional values of
conquer of destroying the will of other
people these are the kind of things a
leader needed to do and that Drax
because of his nature of trying to make
apocalypse a better place
would ultimately be unsuccessful in
doing this but ultimately we find that
that Darkseid actually kills his mother
and ends up usurping the role of or I
guess
throne of doctor of apocalypse anyway
and so again this really just kind of
continues to highlight the very dark
element of dark side now another part of
this equation is the crisis on Infinite
Earths because of the fact that Darkseid
was initially given to us by Jack Kirby
as existing outside of all the existing
continuities that were part of the
crisis on Infinite Earths Darkseid
didn't get a reboot it was almost as
though Darkseid and new gods were in
this separate bubble from all of the
other mainstream DC continuity and so it
was very easy for DC during the crisis
on Infinite Earths to pass up Darkseid
to simply say Darkseid is not affected
by this crisis because he exists outside
of this continuity and so as a result he
wasn't rebooted this is the reason why
from the time of Darkseid was given to
us by Jack Kirby and the fourth world
stories leading up to the new 52
Darkseid's continuity was never changed
his origin story always stayed the same
the second origin of Darkseid and the
one that I actually find to be a whole
lot less interesting comes to us in the
new 52 with the Justice League issues
number 23 where I guess issue number 23
point 1 and what we mean here when I say
issue number 23 point 1 is that it's
really more of a companion comic that
the numbering of the Justice League went
to 23 and then we got twenty three point
one twenty three point two twenty three
point three and so on they gave us these
kind of back up origin stories or
explanation features to a lot of what
was interesting to people in the Justice
League story but the problem here was
that this story really kind of really
felt like I had kind of a of a rushed
feel to it in the sense that it was just
kind of thrown together at the last
minute and it would just kind of slam
together and just thrown out there to
the reader and what we're told here is
that at some point in the distant past
the planet that USS was residing on was
inhabited by various denizens that
seemed to farm the land that his brother
along with his sister were farming
alongside him but that they also seemed
to worship the old gods out of fear
indicating that in this origin the old
gods haven't died yet
now while the sister of us and her
husband I guess expressed their fear in
terms of their hopeful prayers by
appealing to the old gods praying to the
old gods don't kill them different
things like that
yuck sass expresses an extreme hatred
for the old gods and in fact even goes
as far as to climb was referred to as
the fir
Mountain and basically kill the old gods
off and so what greg packs telling us
here is rather than using Jack Kirby's
origin story where the new gods were
already or I'm sorry the old gods were
already dead and
Darkseid along with the high father
became the new gods
instead they actually killed the old
gods and then usurper power and become
the new gods and that's in fact what
happens here when you kills the old gods
he usurps their power he actually takes
their energy and is transformed into
Darkseid now a lot of the things that go
on here how it was he absorbed their
energy different things like that that's
not explained to us that's not given to
us we're simply just told here's how
things happen and we're just kind of
left to assume that this is the absolute
origin here now the other half of this
equation is the brother of I guess the
brother-in-law so to speak of you excess
in the sense that the one of the last
dying members of the old gods had
basically given all of their power to
the brother of USS and so the brother of
USS was born into the role of being the
high father and so this basically
established how it was the high father
and Darkseid came into existence they
had basically killed the old gods
usurped the power of the old gods and
then they formed apocalypse and they
form new Genesis respectively but again
this is just kind of thrown together
this origin is not nearly as intriguing
I think as the original origin from Jack
Kirby's fourth world story but it really
just kind of serves the purpose of
telling us how Darkseid came to be with
that being said we're going to go ahead
and bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it if you did let me
know and I will catch you guys later
peace
I don't wanna fade out of your memory
you
we know I have my toe
[Music]